you've worked with grant cardone
and a lot of people on the internet talk
[ __ ] about him but as people who have
worked with him directly
what was your
experience like so for context um laila
bought me a christmas gift two years ago
which was four one-on-one calls with
grant because it was like available on
the website and she called and the sales
guy didn't even know that he could sell
it and so she had to get transferred to
a manager because he didn't she was like
i'm trying to give you 130 000 or 100
whatever it was thousand dollars for
four hours and he's like i'm not sure
and the manager was like i'm so sorry
about that i will be happy to accept
your money and so uh
anyways uh we've we've done three calls
with grant um
they've been they've been very valuable
i will say that
every experience we've had with grant
has been positive uh he's been attentive
he's taken notes during our calls he's
asked about things that we'd spoken
about the last time um he waits to try
and provide you know contextual feedback
um overall
and um overall it was a great christmas
gift for me because like what do you
what do you get someone who can get
themselves you know whatever and for me
the thing that i love more than anything
is just knowledge you know what i mean
like everything i did so and sometimes
the knowledge gets rarer and rarer and
harder to
find right and especially stories and
experiences like they're the most
valuable things because if i have a
story i can get the lessons from the
experience without having to go through
it and so i always think those are the
most valuable things of all and um but
yeah i mean
i think people will hate anyone who's
who's who's very big
i was going to say what do you think
what do you think it is that causes
people to rise
he's super polarizing i mean he makes
very uh you know strong claims he talks
about money a lot of people just hate
anyone who talks about money he has
money a lot of people hate people who
have money he shows off the money that
he has which a lot of people just hate
because it makes them feel a certain way
about what you know their lives um
yeah and i think
polarizing is usually what i think it
means is that people speak in absolutes
yeah so if somebody doesn't believe what
he believes they believe that him saying
that makes them wrong and so then they
immediately say i'll hate you so that
then it basically discredits anything
that you're saying so i feel good about
myself right but i think a lot you i
mean you know a lot of people don't have
that self-awareness i mean i get people
all the time and i think i try to add a
lot of context of like hey there's no
right or wrong they're like [ __ ] you you
know
yeah
it's it's strange with nuance right when
people add caveats in
what ends up happening is
they dilute down the impact of the
messaging in the hopes that they're
going to front load a little bit of
criticism
uh defense defense so um
seth godin came on the show and he told
me about he's got one of the biggest
blogs on the planet right he's been
writing daily for
15 years or something absolutely wild
and uh he said it was about 10 12 years
ago he removed comments from his blog
this is when medium and and sub stack
and stuff didn't exist and people said
you can't remove comments from your blog
it's a blog a blog has comments and he's
like no i can and i am and the reason
that i am is i know
as the audience grows every blog post is
going to become a little bit longer with
a little bit more caveats in there with
a little bit more exposition and nuance
and a lack of commitment because i'm
always going to be playing defense ahead
of what's going to appear in the
comments below and say what you want
about grant like the guy's committed to
the views that he has you know and that
degree two things happened with that one
is you're right it creates a delta
between what his view is and what your
view is that can't be breached by you
saying oh but he did say sometimes or i
think it's like this and the other thing
that happens with that is that you
cannot
it it causes people to feel
uncomfortable seeing somebody that's
that certain about anything because it
shows into very harsh light
i
i don't believe anything that much and
this guy's talking about something which
is
pretty aspirational with that degree of
um confidence that i wish that i had to
get point yeah
oh yeah a lot of people don't like him i
admire him for it so i think a lot of
people don't understand the goal right
like his goal and he's very transparent
is not to be liked his goal is to be
known
and i think that's a very powerful
nuance like he wants to be known
and so if he has he's happy to have more
haters he doesn't care i really like
having spoken to him i mean maybe on
some deep emotional level like it's
there but like
i
he has trained himself to love the hate
and he's like you know what haters do
they talk about you more than anyone
else does he's like you know what that
does gets more people in my world he's
like when i he did that stunt where he
pretended like he lost all his money at
the beginning of kovid then like so many
people hated him he's like look at my
stats bro he's like website's up 200
sales are up 200 he's like look at the
stats man
and so like he it's just it's purely
about what you know does this serve me
and i think grant is very good about
ruthlessly prioritizing like the things
that serve him and cutting out things
that do not and so in that way and this
is just for everyone like
i said at the very beginning but if
someone is making more money than me
they are better at the game than i am in
some way and so
i think just from a fundamental
standpoint of belief about who to look
for or what to look for or where to look
rather
for information
look at people who are ahead of you
ideally far ahead of you and then look
at the delta and say one of these deltas
is if that is what i want one of these
deltas is the right way to do it
and there may not be this particular
tactic but the principle behind it
might be what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace